the president has been
committed to the refugee program into
rebuilding it
and regaining our status as a world
leader
in the refugee affairs since day one
and that has been unwavering uh we're
very proud of
the announcement today and it reflects
that an enduring commitment
that was homeland security secretary
alejandro mayorkas on president biden's
decision
to quadruple the cap on refugees allowed
into the u.s this year
it comes as the biden administration is
still struggling with the surge of
unaccompanied minors on our southern
border
former acting ice director tom homan
joins us now he's also a fox news
contributor
tom maybe you could help explain to
people the difference between somebody
who is crossing illegally and even
seeking asylum versus
the refugee program
well first of all let me respond to what
the secretary said about restoring our
leadership in in
the refugee program first of all what
they fail to tell the american people
is that we lead the world in the number
of immigrants that we welcome to this
country we got 45 million immigrants in
this country
we represent out of all the migration in
in the world migrant population the
united states has 20
even though it's 195 countries we have
20 we welcome more than 1.1
million immigrants in this country every
year we already are the world's leader
we're the most giving country in the
world
as far as a refugee uh program these are
people that apply from their home
country because they're escaping fear
and persecution
and these are the most serious and again
president trump
decreased that number and joe biden
agreed with them he agreed to 12
000 at the beginning of the year but
again once again he voted to the
aggressive left
and i've said this many times on your
show he sold out to progress left to win
the election
he used to believe in border berries
used to believe in immigration
enforcement
then because he wanted the votes from
the progressive left he said i'm going
to end
my remain in mexico program i'm going to
stop building the wall i'm going to have
more torment deportations i'm going to
abolish the ice
and he'll follow through and make those
promises with executive orders this is
just
yet another example he made the right
decision the beginning of the year
but he voted to progress the left again
it doesn't make sense it's a bad time
when when the border is out of control
to increase that cap
and there's also this there was a the
administration is going to announce 4
billion dollars
in foreign aid to the northern triangle
countries of course that's what we know
that kamala harris the vice president
she said that that's what she's going to
be in charge of trying to do the
diplomacy with them so here's this money
coming
congressman comer and jason smith wrote
this
it is worrisome that the
administration's solution isn't to
reinstate those policies or replace them
with workable solutions
but instead to funnel more money to pay
countries to dissuade their citizens to
break u.s
laws particularly countries with
corruption concerns
and the corruption issue that is real
tom
it absolutely is real look the president
president trump didn't pay ransom
he had he had he had agreements with all
these countries on a third state country
agreements
but the buying administration destroyed
him on day one even though they were
working
and president trump wasn't paying ransom
look we've been down this road i've done
this for over three decades
we've given these countries billions of
dollars it doesn't work and here's why
they can make a few dollars if they stay
in their home country or they can come
and
actually speak louder and worse they see
thousands of people coming to our
borders
they see thousands of people being
released and not being detained
they know they can get a job here
because the bite administration also has
stopped ice
from doing work site enforcement
operations they can come here not be
detained
be released get a job here and based on
other promises by administration they'll
get free health care
why would you not want to come to the
greatest country on earth this simply is
not going to work we've been we've done
this over and over again
and second thing i'll say you can't buy
these countries with a few billion
dollars because mexico alone last year
mexico received over 40 billion
remittance payments
from illegal aliens working here that
sent the money back to mexico
40 billion dollars in the mexican
economy they didn't have to train these
people they want to provide them social
services
you can't outspend that so none of these
countries want to stop illegal
immigration when it comes right down to
it
because it makes so much money on the
remittances that's a that's a really
important point
um how how would you spend four billion
dollars right now if you know if you had
if they gave you four billion dollars
and said put this towards helping solve
this crisis at the border what would you
do
i continue building the wall because the
walls work where the surges come right
now pay attention that's where the surge
is coming
they're coming where there's not a wall
the data clearly shows every place they
built a wall illegal immigration has
went down
illegal drug flows went down finished
building the wall
i was i've been down the border four
times the last two months and the board
was trying to say the same thing if we
had a wall in this area
we wouldn't have the surgery we have
that would force migrants to
a port of entry where they don't have to
pay at criminal cartels women won't be
sexually assaulted
children won't drown in the river it
just makes sense the biden
administration has created
a vastly inhumane system where
where parents are putting their kids in
the arms of criminal cartels children
are dying
women are getting sexually assaulted we
see it every day there's more and more
deaths in that border
because of the policies that by
administration tom holman always
pleasure to have your
thoughts thank you so much